everything you just said
makes so much sense it's as if you were
in my brain yeah and you
nailing it i mean
wow needed to hear that thank you yeah
she really did what the [ __ ] is going on
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters duo
legends icons living what you call an
icon
party's favorite fans whoa
christine and sophia can i just say um
the amount of responses from my friends
that people were saying about how much
we loved venom and tom hardy for the
last six minutes of the last episode if
you guys are a true listener go back
listen to our last episode is he the one
um and apparently
apparently
purely people really liked it and you
know what i find really funny
when i hate an episode after we record
it it's often the one that people like
like the most and it was so interesting
because i couldn't understand maybe my
girlfriend was saying that it was
because i had a mix of us giving advice
but also us being quirky and funny and
then the transition
but i i don't know maybe are we just
finally getting good at this podcast
thing i can't tell
yeah but we're also you guys still in
florida as you can see this is not a
studio this is not
la it's not the old studio in palm beach
but we're back to the zoom interview and
i know
some of y'all don't love it complained
about the audio if i see a one star
because of this
i'm coming after you but
we promise you
we just finished our interview with our
guest today
and when i tell you it is worth it
to listen to this whole interview sophia
and i learned so freaking much yeah she
is a life of relationship expert she's a
life coach she's she teaches us so many
things about
well it's simon
no what jessica brought is all about how
we attach to partners and how it also
was something that maybe we had in the
past with our parents and what we how we
how we perceive our partners
sorry i'm so excited about jessica
basically how you were raised in your
attachment style as an infant is how you
date today and we get into the whole
thing how to handle someone that is a
more anxious partner how to actually be
single and thrive the benefits of online
dating literally every question that you
want asked that is a deep question is
going to be answered on this episode i
mean it's awesome so before we get into
the interview with jessica
sophia
do you have a question for me
are you stressed out
all the time
am i am i always stressed out do you
think
all the time
well you know you guys did you know at
least 75 to 90 of all doctor visits are
for stress related issues that's
interesting well probably because many
of us are operating in survival mode
expecting our skin bodies and minds to
thrive
when really we're running on empty i'm
always looking for a solution and now we
finally found one to change this reality
we love this new purpose-led
california-based cbd brand hemp prima
they are dedicated to helping you rise
above any modern day stress so every day
is a little better with their doctor
formulated clinically validated high
performing products for the skin body
and mind so if you're not sure where to
start try prima's the daily cbd capsules
to help relieve stress so if you're
needing a night of restful sleep without
waking up groggy in the morning which is
what happens when i have too much
melatonin sleep tight will give you the
best sleep that you've been dreaming of
yes this product is something sophia and
i are obsessed with
cbd is the way to go yeah and i know
probably people are out there oh it
doesn't work
no no no it works so let me get you guys
in on this offer prima is offering our
listeners an exclusive limited time 20
percent off offer with the code unwaxed
you guys 20 so head to prima dot co with
the code word unlocks to receive limited
time 20 off offered and get the relief
you deserve so you can feel your very
best every single day okay without
further ado
we're about to
get into one of my favorite interviews
that we've had on the show truly so stay
tuned for that
okay you guys
as you know
sophie and i love giving relationship
advice on this podcast but today
we are bringing an expert in today we
have psychotherapist author of anxiously
attached relationship coach and founder
of the self-full method her method helps
couples create balanced partnerships and
break toxic patterns through effective
communication which is something
we can definitely take definitely no
doubt of that this is jessica baum
jessica
thank you so much for coming on the show
today i mean sophie and i really try to
help our listeners with relationship
advice but to be quite frank um i think
we give some of the worst advice i've
ever heard yeah i think we almost beat
around the bush for what exactly the
answer is i think that you can
definitely provide our listeners with
the right way to approach anything
involving dating or communication
yeah thank you for having me i'm so
excited and i think it can get be
complicated so i'm happy to sit here
today and kind of explain some of these
things um so your listeners can get a
better idea of what's going on inside
their relationship inside their body why
their thoughts are certain ways it's
important to get this information out
there
definitely right off the bat i was
thinking about it today because you
counsel a lot of uh couples whether
they're in a marriage or not in marriage
or everything in between what's one
question or one concern
that you seem to be a repetitive pattern
like what is one thing that is almost
the most common problem in most
relationships
most commonly people uh have different
attachment needs and um
i often see one person in the in the
dynamic needing more connection meaning
more time maybe deal with conflict a
little differently and then the other
person deals wants has different needs
and deals with conflict a different way
so there's this like
kind of a power struggle around how and
what we really need and how do we
actually really understand what's really
going on except the you know the fight
about constantly like date night or our
needs not getting met can become very
surface level when really they're really
deep deeper issues that are going on
that can be worked through when you
understand your own needs and your
partner's needs a little bit more right
and when i was going through your
stocking your instagram page it was kind
of exciting because i took a psychology
class and one thing i saw a lot in the
class was about different attachment
styles as you just mentioned and i
really had fun learning about the
different types and i didn't even
realize there was something like that
where there was a name for it and i
think it would be really important to i
know there's four right there's like
four main ones could you explain what
they are and what they
represent and what they mean sure and i
think it's awesome that though like the
regular world is starting to get really
interested in this i think it's more
important than knowing your horoscope
when it comes to dating
and so we have it backwards yeah so i'm
like looking at my guy going oh you're
this like i don't know if we can do it
yeah you know attachment styles are
really patterns and so they're the ways
in which we adapted when we were really
young to stay in connection or to
survive
and a good chunk of the population has
secure attachment which just means they
have a really good sense of self-esteem
they're comfortable being really close
and they're also comfortable with space
in a relationship and so they kind of
transition really well however even
secure people can get anxious or
avoidant if the partnering is so it's a
two-way street
then we have
anxious attachment which is the one that
i focus on and those people
need more reassurance they need more
connection because when they were little
they had a little inconsistency so they
might get love and then
feel like they're not going to get it
again so they always feel like they're a
little bit empty or they need a little
bit more contact they have struggle with
people who shut down or distance it
creates a lot of anxiety and fear in
them because of how they kind of adapted
as a child
then we have avoidant attachment and
it's interesting because anxious and
avoidant tend to really attract each
other and
i can go into detail if you want but
that attachment style tends to
um learn that i can't trust my needs or
gonna get met emotionally or maybe the
parent wasn't as emotional i didn't have
an emotional iq or they smothered the
child too much so they learned to shut
down and they they're a little bit more
the lone wolf they're um more
independent they actually excel really
well in life in like more of
accomplishments but they really struggle
with um emotions and they struggle
depending on other people so anxious
people can be a little over dependent
and i use that cautiously because when
they depend on the right people they
actually thrive
and avoidant people tend to not trust
enough people to really be vulnerable
and learn healthy dependency because of
their childhood and then there's
disorganized which is actually embedded
patterns of both because we take on more
than just our primary caregiver we can
take on both our parents but that's when
someone can get scared when they get too
close to someone and they're scared when
they're far away and so they can get
really disregulated in terms of knowing
where to be in relationship to the other
person so if a guy or a girl is kind of
coming after you a lot it can feel ah
and then if they pull away it's jarring
anything it's very jarring because they
don't feel safe
anywhere in the relationship when i
think i just figured out
i think that's my attachment style
wow i do be really careful with it
because it's just embedded patterns and
you might show up that way when
someone's really avoidant or you know
with someone who's not secure those
patterns will come become heightened
when you feel scared so with someone
who's still who's secure you might have
those patterns but they're not as
heightened inside your body
i mean i have so many questions from
what you just said first of all i think
it's so fascinating that the type of
attachment style you have today
correlates to how you were
brought up as a baby and it's
interesting because when you are a baby
you can't take care of yourself you are
so
vulnerable all of the time so it's
really those
few years i mean what age do you think
really
sets you up for what your attachment
style might be yeah and it's such a good
question because i'm sure a lot of
listeners are like but my childhood and
how does that come in play in my
romantic life and their scientific proof
to show this
but from womb to about 18 months our
primary caregiver is standing in as
someone to self-soothe us and we learn
how to co-regulate which means we learn
how to
be in sync with our person and so we
learn these adaptive strategies whether
it's to cry louder which later becomes
an anxious person who's like reaching
out a lot or to shut down because we
can't trust our primary caregiver we
learn these embedded patterns in our
nervous system they kind of get they're
like the foundational blueprint
and then when we become adults
the story changes the narrative changes
but the sensations stay the same so it's
it really is co-regulation is really
about learning to trust your primary
caregiver being a unit because you're
still one energetic unit and the trust
that you have there
actually gives you the foundation to
have trust when you're an adult but if
there's a distrust for whatever reason
and let's say your parents not to blame
parents but let's say your mom was going
through a lot of stress or a lot of
anxiety and she couldn't attune and be
in this flow state with you enough
you're gonna develop a little bit more
of an anxious base because she was
struggling at the time or if your dad
was absent you take that in and it's no
one's fault because our parents are
doing the best they can most of them
but we embed those experience into our
nervous system and then when our partner
we reattach to an adult
our early attachment
strategies and our system gets activated
the same way as when we were a baby so
it can get really confusing but it all
really does go back to like the early
fundamental developmental years that
lays down the foundation for your
nervous system and your response when
you're scared
wow
i feel like it's um it's so interesting
because i think one thing that a lot of
people probably struggle with is even
identifying the fact that they have
this and didn't probably realize until
they got into a relationship that they
were struggling with maybe
some
uh
absentee parents or just to feel like
they weren't getting enough attention or
they felt like they were getting too
smothered and um it's even for me i feel
like sometimes like i can see myself as
more avoided with some things like oh my
god i shut down or i need to push away
because i'm like i'm good on my own i
don't need help i don't need anybody but
then you go back and wait there were so
many things in like past relationships
that i didn't see was a pattern is there
a way that like i could have seen or i
could call myself out and go oh wait
maybe i need to take a step back and fix
these things like how what are some
signs
and small things that are not even
involving a relationship with a
boyfriend or girlfriend that maybe you
do with your friends or you do with
yourself that people can say oh wait
this is something i need to look into i
mean that's a great question and i think
that we have protectors so we can be
anxious but if we are anxious and we
don't get what we need eventually our
protector will be like i can't go there
or this is not working for me or i'm
good on my own i mean that i'm an
anxious person but if you push me hard
enough i'm like i need to go to an
island i need to run away because the
pain is so big and i can't get back into
connection because connection is by our
biological imperative if you can't get
back into connection and it gets too
scary the other reaction is to run away
from it because it's too scary but then
you're not happy on the other side if
you run away from it too much either and
i think you know you how taking out of
the context of romantic relationships
although that's where it shows up the
most we've all had that girlfriend or
even guy friend who's so clingy and so
anxious and they're coming at us and
we're we don't know what to do we're
feeling almost consumed
that's because it's kicking up our own
kind of attachment stuff or we have
another i mean for me if i have a friend
who's like i'm gonna you know go to
dinner with you on thursday night and
then they flake on me
i'm like
really sad because i feel disappointed
and i really was looking forward to that
connection and if that person does it
enough
they're just not a safe person for my
attachment style i love them and i don't
personalize it at all anymore but
knowing like knowing your own needs like
i know i need consistency and if you're
someone with anxious you need to have
consistency you need to have trust in in
order to build
intimacy so knowing your attachment
style and knowing that your partner is
like if your partner's avoidant and i go
through a lot of this in my book you can
still work with it but you really need
to understand the nervous system on the
other end of if if you like you said you
shut down knowing that i'm shutting down
because i'm scared or i'm shutting down
because i'm actually hurting right now
and starting to kind of get underneath
what that behavior is protecting you
from like pulling away is a protection
moving closer is a protection so you're
either protecting yourself from an
abandonment wound
or you're texting yourself also from an
abandonment moon but like a consumed i
don't know if i can meet the need or i'm
gonna let this person down so either way
right
there are protective states so kind of
looking at it that way is that too
complicated
no if that makes sense i honestly want
to pick up one thing um
concerning it just reminded me of
codependency in a relationship that i
want to jump to in one second but for
someone like me and we'll wrap up the
attachment style conversation who
doesn't even know what my attachment
style is how could i figure that out and
how could i
tell my partner
to figure it out as well like is there a
quiz is there actually
it's also important yeah there's a
question
but i also feel like there needs to be
how do people talk to their partner if
they have one of these attachment
problems like if you're in a
relationship and your boyfriend is more
avoidant how do you approach that
situation and you're secure and you're
fine but how do you avoid it or approach
it if he's more anxious
so how would you have that conversation
with someone
if they're if there is one that needs to
be had yeah i mean two so two questions
one i think you can take the attachment
style quiz i do have one i can kind of
send it to you guys but
knowing your embedded kind of tendency
and then know that it's a two-way street
so if you're secure or anxious if you're
if you're anxious and you and you attach
to and avoid it it can work but the
dynamic is gonna be a little bit more
challenging so knowing where your
baseline is there are um tests that are
scientifically proven where you can know
where your baseline is
and once you understand yourself better
i think the conversation you have with
your partner is if you're secure and
your partners avoid it you're not going
to be reactive when they shut down you
might be able to come up with
communication around hey when you're
shutting down
if you can can you send me a text or
when are you going to be back or let me
know that you love me but this is how
you're processing your pain right now
and if you're anxious that might help
settle the anxious person some people
aren't as resourced they literally just
shut down and it can be very
i don't want to use triggering as a word
but it can be very activating because
it's really activating the other
person's system because we want to be in
the connection if someone just ghosts
you that you care about it hurts i mean
it's our natural we're naturally going
to hurt when someone we care about we
can't get in contact with
the degree of sensation and hurt will
vary depending on your attachment style
it will still hurt a secure person but
an anxious person might get even
more anxious
yeah and then lastly because i know that
we want to move into codependency but is
there
oh is there a point in our relationship
where
you need to maybe take a step back from
the relationship and if this person is
like too much on you where you need to
say okay maybe you need to work on
yourself or
is it important to keep going on the
relationship if it's not
that healthy do you know what i'm trying
to say yes like because i know sometimes
it can get a little bit overwhelming i
feel like sometimes when you're taking
on someone's
worries and anxiousness and you try and
you try to communicate you try to fix
everything
is there a point where they just need to
focus on themselves or is there a point
where you just have to keep pushing it
out i love that it's pretty much an
avoidant person's question
uh where when i feel overwhelmed too
much and i date because so what i'm
hearing you say is that maybe you date
people who then
make you
um
the center of their kind of world
you know and so they will they like let
their
their le their sense of self
kind of becomes the relationship like so
an anxious person if you're avoiding or
you're secure they want to stay in this
like
kind of a meshed place with you and they
want to focus on you and if they have a
fear of abandonment they're gonna be
hyper vigilant and focus on you and for
an avoid someone with avoiding
tendencies it can feel really
overwhelming it's like i'm i'm attracted
to you when you can be your you know
yourself and if you're pushing in your
energy
so yes you can have these conversations
but
the intention around the conversation is
this person is scared and they need more
reassurance so while i want them to be
more themselves i need to give them the
reassurance when i have this
conversation that hey
i'm feeling like a little overwhelmed
myself which is my stuff and i will i
love you or i like you a lot and i care
about you
i you know and so i'm going to take a
step back but i want to let you know
that it's i i care about you and this is
just me feeling overwhelmed and most
anxious people will get more anxious
but a healthy or anxious person might be
able to take a step back and it might do
them a favor and then you can breathe
again so and then you might want to step
closer and this is where the dance comes
in oh i'll get closer again and then
they get attached and then it becomes
too overwhelming and then you step back
and this is where we have more of the
cycles
so yeah you can start to really have
these conversations but knowing
the attachment style is that when you
step back you have to make it safe for
them
and when they move forward
they have to make it safe for you so if
they're moving forward out of fear and
they're grabbing on to you they might
need to work with a therapist or a coach
to kind of work with their anxiety if
you're stepping back out of fear you
might need to work with someone or
someone needs to help with the overall
dynamic because it will cycle and cycle
it's like we do these unconscious dances
with each other all the time and it's a
dance around intimacy so the closer we
get the more overwhelmed i get i got to
pull back the closer we get the other
person feels like i could lose this i
got to move forward so we're really
talking about energy here so the
conversation really needs to be around i
feel safe here and the other person's
need is i want to be closer to feel safe
right and that's what we're bumping up
against in in a more anxious avoidant
dance which is really what i'm
fascinated about and i wrote a lot about
is is trying to understand that from a
compassionate lens because both people
are really struggling the avoidant
person isn't trying to hurt you
by pushing you away they're trying to
calm down their system
and so it can feel hurtful and the
anxious person isn't trying to love bomb
you
or like smother you or
need you so much but their system is
only calm when they're close they need a
lot of closeness so sometimes it's it's
a complicated pairing it can work with a
lot of conscious awareness and sometimes
takes a third party to step in and
really help each person see that they're
not hurting each other on purpose this
is literally how they regulate their
system and they're not
they're not co-regulating together
enough or some fear is coming up which
is causing one person to back up or one
person to run closer so once you start
to really understand the underpinnings
compassion starts to come in and then
it's not about the behavior it's like oh
this is what they need to do to feel
safe this is what she needs to do to
feel safe
wow everything you just said
makes so much sense it's as if you were
in my brain yeah and you
nailing it i mean
wow
needed to hear that thank you actually
let's let's move into codependency i've
had a lot of girlfriends a lot of guy
friends
um almost complained to me that oh my
partner is so codependent and it drives
me insane and
sometimes i think that there is a really
negative connotation tied to being
codependent is it necessarily a bad
thing no and i thank you so much for
answering this question codependency
asking this question is a really poorly
termed
word because we are co-regulators
and we need each other
but someone with a more anxious
attachment or insecure base
needs
more and what i mean by that is they
need more reassurance they need more
contact
they need to depend on dependable people
and the only way to heal
is actually relearning how to
co-regulate and lean on the enough
people because that's what builds in our
security so when i trust you enough
that i don't need to contact you all the
time it's when i trust you enough that i
start to feel safe right and if i don't
feel safe is at the root what
trust is at the root of it yeah and it
comes back to parenting again in a felt
sense in your body but
we all have needs right and so i hate
when someone says i'm still i'm too
needy it means that they didn't get
their needs met well when they were
younger and they have to
learn to get their need needs met now
with the right supportive people and
it's not always your romantic
relationship sometimes it can be
but understanding that like you have to
re-parent that part of you because they
don't have the ability to self-soothe as
much so they're always going to run into
the relationship to try to regulate
their system so it's about building
compassion and understanding that this
person struggles with self-regulation
and reaches out probably more than maybe
people's comfort level but if they can
reach out to the right people who can be
present for them they actually build in
our security with neuroplasticity so
it's you know codependency has so much
shame around
and i think i am
i i can identify as a codependent that's
actually how i started my journey and i
read every single book on codependent
and you think oh the solution is to
become independent no that's not a
solution
the solution is to become interdependent
and that's what you didn't get as a baby
so the more i can trust you what is that
so interdependency is and that's where
the pendulum is like codependent
independent it's like no the
interdependent is i
trusted you enough as a baby but also as
an adult to come together and to leave
and you get to be all of you and i get
to be all of me and we can do this
merger and this leaving someone who has
a little more codependent it's really
the anxious attachment they want to stay
here
and this is where they're comfortable
and um you know it's about being here
with safe people that gets them to be
stronger and more interdependent but
it's the more trust that they have in
their support system the more
interdependent they become and they're
like i'm not alone you know i'm not
gonna have to grab on so fast and
understanding what needs weren't met as
a baby or as a young child is what needs
to be re-parented
and healed as an adult or else we'll try
we'll replay those kind of
trauma reenactments or trauma bonds a
little bit in our adult relationship
unconsciously i mean we're all doing
this unconsciously
or you know on the subconscious level
right and i i you know it's so
interesting when you're talking about uh
codependence and interdependence and i
feel like there has to be always a
communication to keep that probably
interdependence constant because
sometimes when you're in the new
relationship
it becomes so overwhelming and you're
only with each other and then you avoid
all your friends or if you're in a
long-term relationship
it's very consistent and it's
comfortable and you stay with just that
one person and sometimes when you become
codependent it's not a bad thing but you
tend to make your world a little bit
smaller because you just have your one
person um and to be interdependent do
you think that there needs to be
a
chat that has to be brought up probably
yearly or whatever it is just to remind
each other like we need to have
our independence but also our
co-dependence on each other to make this
relationship the healthiest it can be is
it like how do you bring up that
conversation without it sounding
like
there's a problem that's a really great
question and i it's too it's two part
one every relationship goes through
traditional phases so the honeymoon
phase the power struggle and then you
have a more conscious phase
and in the honeymoon phase we'll call
that the beginning of a relationship a
lot of this is
happening and so we're getting closer
and closer and closer and this feels so
good and there's a lot of um
i talk about the neural chemicals that
are actually being released in the brain
and it's normal to lose yourself a
little
the problem is when we get closer and
closer to someone we are becoming more
intimate we touch a wound and eventually
someone pulls away and that's when we
have our first rupture so we get closer
and then as the relationship the
safety's built then we start to do this
but if safety is not built and someone
just yanks away because something got
touched then that can be scary but i
think what you're asking and it's a very
tough thing
but keeping balance in the beginning of
a relationship to some degree getting
lost a little is nice but keeping your
support system around keeping your
hobbies at play
keeping your world as intact as possible
so that you don't completely lose your
sense of self although i think part of
that loss is normal because then i think
you fall back into yourself so there's a
little bit of a fluid thing so i mean
you're supposed to spend a lot of time
in the beginning you're building the
attachment but the attachment dynamics
don't always play out in the beginning
they only play out when the wounds are
being activated when the system starts
to kind of alert that that something's
scary so the beginning of a relationship
can look really good and it can last the
honeymoon phase can last from two years
um two days to two years i mean and
longer or shorter that's what the
research shows so you don't really know
the full dynamic in the beginning and i
think losing yourself a little is
healthy but if you have a secure sense
of self or a sense of self you'll pull
you'll want to go back into yourself and
it should be a gradual integration and a
kind of a coming and a going but this in
the beginning is kind of normal and
you're really excited and there's a lot
of chemicals right and then yeah and
then you kind of find
your way of moving together and i don't
think i think relationships are fluid i
don't you know it'd be nice if we could
do you know there are periods of time
where someone's a little bit more
independent and if you're anxious you
have to deal with the the abandonment
that comes up
or someone needing a you know someone
maybe needing a lot more
like
uh soothing or reassurance because
they're really scared and if that
doesn't kick up your anxiety being able
to offer that to that person you know
but it's not about staying in those
modes because when you can offer that
they calm down and then you usually
don't stay but if it kicks up your own
anxiety you're just gonna pull away even
more
right so why do you think people
lose themselves when they get into a
relationship i mean the first thing i
can think of because i had a really bad
habit of
shape-shifting
into the type of woman that i thought
this man wanted me to be
and
it became the sort of vicious cycle and
i kept thinking maybe you know he won't
accept me for who i am so why do you
think when you're in
sort of maybe a co-dependent
relationship that you just sort of
lose who you are in the core
well i think that's so
again i'm not just saying you guys are
asking like the best questions ever and
but i think a lot of people
want to get love and they want to be
loved and as an adaptation or a way we
try to be what the other person wants
and so you know it happens as a way
to secure love or to secure the
connection so we we're really good at
figuring out what the other person might
want and that's an adaptation that you
can look at even probably started out
younger like when i want something i
know how to read the room i know how to
figure out what that person wants i'm
going to change to give them exactly
what they want the problem with that is
we spend so much time trying to get that
person to want us right
that we're not even sure if we want them
so all this energy is spent on
trying to get them to want us where and
i tell i tell people and women and all
people this all the time like you have
to go in saying like you're interviewing
this person too but people are so scared
of rejection and want to be wanted it's
like then the person picks you and
you're like wait a minute i don't even
know if i like this person i spend so
much time trying to figure out what they
want so it's really it's better if
you're
can work through some of that rejection
and really think
if you're going to put your best self
forward no matter who you are and rose
color glasses are normal in the
beginning of a relationship and we can
talk about that but if you can be more
authentic in yourself and realize
eliminating people who don't really like
your
don't jive well with who you are is
actually going to get you to your person
faster
rather than shape-shifting and trying to
get them to pick you that's a game so
you kind of kind of catch yourself with
those things is that helpful
yeah well it really reminds me of
another theory that
i know you know quite well the chemistry
versus attachment style because again i
would
show so much attention and anyone that
would give me just the slightest amount
of effort and now looking back i
question it thinking did i really like
them or did i want to be in a
relationship or did i just like the
temporary attention so
uh
why do
myself and other people are attracted to
the sort of i don't want to say toxic
but a little bit of this toxic mindset
of
going for someone that they know isn't
necessarily right for them
but still doing it because they just
want
maybe a relationship
well yeah i mean thank you for sharing
that it's very vulnerable of you but i
think what you're sharing is i go for
unavailable people and sometimes i place
my sense of self-worth
on if i can get this person to like me
and there's a sense of
that has a charge for you and many
you know and so
if you're going for someone who's
unavailable it can be a chase and it can
be a reward if you get that person to
take the bait and it could be healing a
deeper wound it's not really healing
your wound but you think it is around
you sensing that there was someone
unavailable in your life before and
there's an attraction to
the lone wolf or the unavailable type
that runs much deeper
than
like why you're attracting that because
they're likely to leave you anyway so
you're almost recreating the wound so to
speak but there's no blame here it's
just about looking and saying
okay i i
am attracted to people who aren't really
available
and so maybe that's my way of recreating
this sense of self-worth through an
earlier experience or maybe when a
really available person comes up and
sees me i'm like whoa
i think it's great that you guys are in
such different places in your
relationship and you can each of you
independently and i think you know it's
good that we're here today talking about
the early phases so the end phases the
power struggle how do we get conscious
about these things how do we know if we
have a good match ahead of us right and
yeah that's the thing is like it's kind
of interesting because we're in two
different places in our relationship and
still the question is always at the end
day is this person for me like i'm
wearing the rose colored glasses and i'm
in this very new relationship and
everything seems completely perfect and
this honeymoon phase i make jokes saying
when is it going to be over because i'm
like when's the when's the nail going to
drop or something going to happen and
then for her it's a totally different
situation and it's still the same
question at the end of the day um and
when it comes to both what is the
how do you know you're fighting for the
right person yeah like how do you know
that with the rose colored glasses and
the newness that's the right person or
that the ends of the relationship that
it's still the right i mean it's it's so
true that in the beginning like you said
um i mean i've never been in a
two-year-long uh honeymoon phase which
sounds amazing i'm like sounds amazing
but
you know when that phase does fizzle out
i don't know if we're attracted to the
excitement of a new relationship or like
wait what happened to it it was so much
fun in the beginning
or if it's just a cycle that's natural
and we have to get used to so yeah again
the question really is
how do you know that this person is
genuinely a good match for me or
not um yeah and i felt like something
when you were sharing um
that that was like a deep question for
you
i think that um
so every
relationship
a psychotherapist called it ruptures but
every relationship has conflict
and how you handle conflict is an
indicator on the intimacy and growth
factor of the relationship so in the
beginning you can talk about how you
handle pain what do you do around
conflict what are your needs what's your
attachment style if you feel comfortable
having those and you know starting to
understand how this person adapted and
until you have conflict because really
healthy conflict is about coming back to
the table and building empathy
so when you have conflict and you're in
a healthy relationship you come back and
you start to see each other's lenses
rather than debate all day as to who's
right because you're both right you're
both in pain so when you can build
empathy for each side
that is the relation the resolution
because that brings you closer
so conflict is normal how you handle
conflict is normal empathy is a big
component on both sides
and learning to compromise and what your
needs are what their needs are what's
really going on and how do we compromise
actually grows the relationship closer
but you need
humility you need
empathy and you need you need a couple
key ingredients because or else you're
just going to stay in defenses and
you're going to be arguing about like
stuff up here when it's really
vulnerability like both people need a
degree of vulnerability too but when you
have those things and the right tools
the conflict brings you closer so it's
not that the relationship doesn't go
through murky waters but as the murky
waters get dealt with in a healthy way
you come out the other end stronger so
if one person is lacking empathy or you
can't really you're having these and i
imagine a lot of people have a lot of
conversations around really surface
level things when we're really they're
being hurt deep down and the couple
isn't able to get conscious about what's
really going on so it's like these
cycles that we get stuck in yeah so i
think you know knowing how you fight
i don't know knowing how you
resolve conflict knowing how you can
handle pain
knowing how your partner handles pain
having a talk before and say hey listen
we're in this beautiful phase but that's
not going to last forever
let's make sure we can resolve things
together too and come out stronger and
then sometimes you don't know fully
until you're in a rupture or conflict or
if something happens and you learn okay
we can come back together and we have
these meaningful talks we might not be
changing each other's behaviors but
we're starting to understand each
other's behavior from a deeper level and
that actually is what gets you to a more
conscious relationship
yeah i think that's a really
it's very well said and i think it also
takes a very mature
emotionally
intelligent person and aware person to
do that because i think a lot of people
um
don't even want to come to terms with
how they feel or don't admit that
they're
an anxious type or a nervous or whatever
it is so i mean yeah yeah open dialogue
is truly the only way to do it i would
love to talk about sort of the opposite
um
and feeling really lonely whether you're
in a relationship or not and there's
just weird
negativity surrounding being lonely you
know for
being alone like you feel scared you
think it's embarrassing you're anxious
uh
and
like actually you had posted something
that i found that was really profound
that you could be
out of a relationship and feel lonely
and you could be in a
super long marriage and still feel
extremely lonely so
how can someone shift their mindset from
thinking it's not such a bad thing to be
lonely
so it's definitely not a bad thing to be
single and i think you're right like
there's a lot of
stigma i think it's moving in the right
direction but i understand um where
you're going with that
i think that
like i said so being single can be the
most thriving place and healing place if
you have good connections
and we're meant to be in relationship at
the end of the day but we need to spend
some time with ourselves
getting to know ourselves so we have a
secure sense of self and part of that is
being in community and having intimate
friendships and feeling really safe in
the world and not needing some
relationship to give us a sense of
identity or meaning that's a really
fundamental start to kind of building
who you are so you can bring that to the
relationship and it makes me sad because
you guys are a lot younger than me that
it's still kind of seen as like oh
you're single because i actually think
i've seen some of the most fulfilling
people
in between relationships for a while
have amazing friendships and do amazing
things and then someone new floats into
their life when they're ready and we
don't always have a crystal ball and we
can't always predict that so trusting
that the quality of your relationships
whether it's friendships or romantic is
important and i'll caveat that with
if you're in a relationship and you had
any abandonment or neglect in your
childhood and your partner shuts down
stonewalls you she stonewalls you
um is emotionally unavailable they're
gonna kick up any loneliness that was
already there and you're gonna have to
be and that's a big piece of what i talk
about too in the book you're gonna have
to be with this part of yourself because
even the perfect relationship someone
forgets to call back someone shuts down
like these are things that we all have
to go through so knowing what is kind of
getting kicked up in you and kind of
knowing that either way you're gonna
have to do the work and i i just think
that we're always in flow
you know and we're in flow with a group
of people like our soul pack you know
and so knowing that sometimes when
you're not in a romantic relationship
you're still in a flow state and and
pulling in more awesome
connections is actually a way to get
fulfillment before you call in
your new person so to speak and then
right pull that person in it's not about
that person it's about integrating them
into what you've already built like you
don't leave your world because there's a
new person you say okay now i'm going to
spend some time with you but then i'm
going to bring you into my beautiful
world and i'm going to go into yours and
we're going to form this new
co-created world
where you know i still keep my friends
and my hobbies and this and that and and
so we're joining energies but we're not
dropping our world completely so
actually being single is a really really
beautiful and healthy place to work on
all these things and healing your
attachment can happen when you're single
with really supportive friendships and
it's sometimes a safer place to start if
you're not already in a relationship
i i
completely agree i think
more people need to be proud of being
single because that those
moments that you have with just yourself
are really that you got to take that
time to figure out who you are what you
want what you're looking for and then
when you
have come to terms with that then the
right person will like you said puzzle
piece into your life in a really
cohesive way i think it's important that
you also like mention like you should
still go out with your friends you
should still go date you should figure
out who you are because it's i think a
lot of people they'll shut down they'll
go you know like i shouldn't date
anybody or i shouldn't be doing this or
shouldn't they make like these
definitive statements when you're a
human being you're a well-rounded person
you should go out and keep that
communication with whoever you're dating
and your friendships and with yourself
and keep those hobbies and then that
person will come along and i feel like
sometimes when someone's been in a
long-term relationship they'll probably
go completely opposite like they won't
date for a while do you think that it's
important if even if you're in an
anxious attachment style to
keep dating to practice because if
you're newly into the single dating game
what do you suggest people do to
approach it the easiest way yeah because
you sometimes forget your little tips
and tricks sometimes you get you lose it
so far behind like how am i ever gonna
find the person because i haven't put
myself out there or i feel like every
guy i go out with it's horrible so how
do you reshift that mindset and go the
best and whole way you can well a lot of
what you're saying was correct so if
you're grieving a relationship and
you're feeling a lot of abandonment it's
actually not the best time to go out and
date you could end up
re-re-hurting yourself you're better off
dating your friends and and what i mean
by that is being around really safe
people um and because if you go out and
you're still in a very abandoned or
wounded place and the date doesn't go
well it can send you spiraling so
knowing that like where am i do i need
to build up my my support network and
feel really secure in myself before i
put myself back out there but the piece
that you said that was right so you
don't want to stop your life even if
you're in pain you might want to tend to
that pain and bring to pain to someone
but then try to start to do the things
that made you happy before and
eventually and this goes back to a lot
of neural chemicals in the brain you
start to be happier in your life then
you can start dating
now if you're someone who's
not going through a grief process and or
and you know i'm not i'm spiritual so
like if someone lands in your plate and
you're not you're not dating from a
sense of needing you're dating from a
sense of openness right right if you're
needing go need on someone who can meet
those needs not a new person that's
person who's like jumping from one thing
to the next go need on a therapist go
need on your family go go and try to
transfer that but if you're open if
you're just like open and you know a
date comes by or you know if you're open
and it just kind of flows fine and if
you're also done a work and you feel
really good and you want to put yourself
out there and start dating again that's
okay too it's kind of like where is it
coming from is it coming from this
abandonment wound and then you could
just really hurt yourself and i need to
build that support system back up and
myself back up or is it coming from a
place of i can be open sit down with
another soul meet them leave if it
doesn't work out i'm not in shambles so
you kind of just want to check in with
yourself and see where you're at does
that answer right it's 100 it's all
about having the right intention going
into it yeah trying to fill a void
that
you know
you still want to fill that void but you
want to fill it with people who actually
can help you fill it and then you can
sustain it yeah the healthiest void to
fill like you want it doesn't have to be
a guy or a girl that you're dating it
can be your friends it can be the
hobbies that you do it can be the family
that you have whatever it is that is the
most comforting and warm sense of like
securing place so yeah hypothetically
just to wrap up this
amazing yeah i love this episode amazing
i would talk to you for hours more if i
really could
but say if we are
ready to date we have the right
intention
i don't know if we're millennials or gen
z but some people would argue that the
best way to meet someone today is
through online dating and i saw that you
posted someone how to how you
suggest
online dating to find the most success
now how would you go about it because
we've dabbled and i can't say it was a
success for me
so what do you recommend um that's a
good question i mean again i think a lot
of people who want a date who would go
to a bar and it's like then they're
scanning the room for who's available
i just think online dating
and i say this gently puts a lot of
available people in front of you
everybody's being vulnerable i'm on here
i'm looking for a partner or i'm looking
for this i'm looking for that so you're
you're kind of eliminating the looking
process but you got to be careful
because a lot of people online are now
just addicted to the online process of
like going on dating
it becomes like a cycle that can be
really toxic too so while it eliminates
the i want to date where do i go and
here you go here's all these people you
still have to know how to sort through
that and find a good match which i do
talk a lot about in one of the courses
which i'm actually giving that course
away for free for pre-orders if
anybody's
interested so that that it's dating for
anxious people but really how do you
know
how to sort you got to represent
yourself in an authentic way how do you
know if someone's a good match and it's
yeah there's a lot of variables out
there but i i think having options is
good if you have the right ability to
sort through what's right for you
i love that you've made it less sound
like that because i have had always a
hard time to put a positive spin on the
online dating and it really is just
people everyone on a dating app is
looking for love in their own way maybe
it's not serious maybe it is serious but
you know it's like we're looking for
love but yes deciding who is that
um
you have just been such an amazing guest
like i feel like this is so
serendipitous like for that this all
worked out like it's time to yeah
a lot of our listeners
ask these questions so a lot of it is
generated from people that genuinely
have no idea what to do and i think you
just shed a lot of light yeah to all of
us so thank you so much for coming
everyone's going to benefit from your
book anxiously attached i mean like if
you guys loved this like you're gonna
definitely love her and what she's
written and i'm gonna for sure pick one
up because yeah i can tell everyone
where they can find your courses your
book your social media yeah so i we're
gonna send you guys a link i think but
my book is anxiously attached you can
get it right on amazon but on be self
full.com that's my um my website if you
put your information or the coupon code
into the website um there's a bunch of
like meditations and the free course
isn't is offered and all these things
are offered to help you start now
because this is a few weeks out
um so yeah so you can google me jessica
baum and anxiously attached on amazon or
beselful.com is my website so you guys
have been awesome too it's it was just a
pleasure to talk to you and it's
so sincere that you guys want to know
about this stuff and yeah it's exciting
for me to talk to people who are like oh
i want this information i really and
it's important to get people this
information because we're all looking
for sustainable quality relationships
and it can be confusing
yeah it can be confusing and i learned a
lot today and you completely exceeded
our expectations so thank you so much
for coming on thank you so we'll see you
guys next tuesday bye guys
[Music]
you